we've just heard from a spokesperson for
the prime minister who said the public
will now be told if the prime minister
is handed a fine for breaking
coronavirus rules something they
weren't admitting to i wouldn't
guarantee uh earlier on today john
yes uh what uh this is the uh the
downing street holds two briefings for
political con correspondents each day
and uh they've just had the afternoon
one and uh that pretty swift u-turn um
this a u-turn a day i don't know if a
u-turn a day keeps the letters to the
1922 committee chairman away but clearly
not because of peter oldest but
yesterday of course number 10 you turned
on the question of publishing the full
sue grey report within a matter of hours
today the same thing has happened this
time on uh whether uh there would in
fact be
uh the number 10 would reveal if the
prime minister was served with a fixed
penalty notice by the metropolitan
police um
having initially said no it's not the
way the police do we do things police
don't generally make these things public
now um number 10 have said this
as the met have made clear generally
speaking with fixed penalty notices
individuals are not published in any way
obviously we're aware of the significant
public interest regarding the pm and
would always look to provide what
updates we can on him specifically
asked if that meant number 10 would say
if he was given a fixed penalty notice
the spokesman said
hypothetically yes
hypothetically so uh not a cast iron
pledge you might say but hypothetically
yes
the hypothetical john
they do don't they yeah
that's what politicians say when they're
in an interview interviewed by uh
presenters like you or correspondents
like me but yeah they've used the word
hypothetically this afternoon but it is
a swift u-turn and clearly comes in
response to pressure i mean for example
uh there was pressure from uh
angela rayner was saying the public had
a right to know and uh sired davey the
lib dem leader said this stinks of a
cover-up by number 10 even richard nixon
believed a country deserves to know
whether their leader is a crook well
they're number 10 are not admitting that
the the prime minister's a crook far
from it
and he continues to insist he's not done
anything wrong but they are now saying
if he gets a fixed penalty notice
hypothetically they'll let us know a
hypothetical yes from downing street i'm
going to keep that one in my back pocket
for an interview with the minister john
thank you john craig with the latest
there